[Applause]
so unnecessary we have to talk about
something that's really going on this is
the only show everyone else all they do
is talk about politics and and us we're
here with Frankenstein and crotch cams
it's a lot of fun that's what we do here
at Late Night with Conan O'Brien and I
couldn't be more proud
but anyway I'm told that there's a
presidential election right around the
corner and that everyone's talking about
it
and and anyway it's something that if
you're a responsible show you have to
cover these things you just do so a few
nights ago we showed a report from our
friend triumph the insult comic dog and
that's right try and point to the third
presidential debate and Tempe Arizona
and he visited the area known as spin
alley to sort of hassle the political
spin doctors and give him a hard time we
showed that the other night let's take a
quick look back it's safe to say I think
one of the great democratic standards
stole a car can you spin a woman into
thinking you don't look gross in the
shower
the point about the stance on gay
marriage the point
you take a peach
[Applause]
no one gets to the heart of the matter
like triumph such an insightful
political mind anyway after that event
triumph visited with the group of
undecided voters because after all the
undecided voters are the ones who will
decide this election they're very
important he visited with them he talked
to them here's what happened
all right we've heard from the spin
daughters
now let's hear what people who have a
soul thought here in Tempe we've
assembled 14 undecided voters in this
depressing hotel bar the representative
group ranging from your average Joe
Sixpack
to your average Joe 12 you're not you're
still undecided so undecided come on
you're so Republican looking looking
sure you're stiffer than Richard Simmons
unwrapping Detroit DVD you watch the
debate yeah I just watched carries know
how knows girl carries knows crew yeah
he's like Carrie this is like Pinocchio
because Pinocchio eyes to Marissa you're
not undecided you hate carry more than
you hate changing your underwear what
issue did you want to hear about tonight
other than lowering the age of consent
it's not there okay no no I knew I knew
a Pekinese who shaved hers like that
you used to be a hippie all terminal
used to protest okay
well good for you give soap a chance
recycle I Bank them they arrested me for
bestiality really stuck out in your
minds Foo Fighters I mean there was
goodness there was a full Fighters
concert here before the debate great
that was a highlight was this any
particular song help you decide between
bush and Kerry fly the fly in the video
I talk for God's sake just whatever you
do you've got to take this process more
seriously set an example for the kids
here I mean our fathers fought for years
for this right you know to not take your
vote seriously that would be like
spending 20 years building the Neverland
Ranch and then not molesting a single
child
[Applause]
doing God's work out there
Francine sometimes I would say we come
back Sarah Michelle Gellar's here